Bogg dis uses a solar panel and
condenser attached to a bike to convert
water vapour from the air into a bottle
of drinking water and sell you fun is a
wood based renewable biodegradable shock
absorbing potential future alternative
to styrofoam Vsauce Kevin here this is
mind blow
Kota wants to charge every device within
30 feet wirelessly in development since
2001 the transmitter which is made up of
thousands of tiny antennas angled
slightly different from one another
receives RF pings from a microchip
receiver embedded on your device and
reflects them back with an increased
power level of up to one watt and the
process is repeated 100 times per second
the charge speed is one fifth to one
third of USB but it continuously charges
untethered until the battery is full
whether it's in your hand pocket or on
the table the concept isn't just for
phones it's for wireless door locks
smoke detectors remote controls video
game controllers for electric
toothbrushes there'll be another five
years before this becomes commercially
available a new smart pill seeks to
measure the gas inside you the impact of
gas on health is poorly understood in
part because it's difficult to measure
inside the gut so the new gas pills
detect hydrogen methane and carbon
dioxide and wirelessly transfer the
results to an app researchers from RMIT
and Melbourne believe this could lead to
a future of optimized diets customized
for all individuals in 1781 Benjamin
Franklin actually proposed to the study
of farts in an essay that was part
science and part humor Franklin cited
the same problems that internal gases
were difficult to understand and measure
he hoped to find a drug that made farts
smell like perfume 235 years later we
may not have realized Franklin's dream
of lavender flatulence but were on the
path to understanding the effects of
diet on gut disorders like IBS and
Crohn's disease fgf21 is a
life-extending immune function boosting
hormone in mice researchers at the Yale
School of Medicine found that increasing
the levels of the hormone produced in
the thymus gland led to a 40% lifespan
extension if and this is a big if that
were to apply to human someday it would
raise the average life expectancy from
about 79 to over 110 years old they do
believe the implications for improving
immune function in the elderly could
help combat
illnesses such as type 2 diabetes and
cancer Anna bots are mobile 3d printing
robots that could fill potholes it was
first tested by repairing skating cuts
in ice by essentially printing ice
precisely depositing water kept just
above freezing for roads the additive
manufacturing robots will need to keep
tar materials at a high temperature so
further research and development is
currently underway sperm bots to help
combat male infertility researchers from
germany have developed magnetically
driven micro helisas
that go over the tail of sperm and act
as motors they've successfully driven
sperm in the lab are still far from
beginning human clinical trials for the
cyborg sperm Michigan engineering is
developing a full-page Braille display
for the visually impaired
the pneumatic display uses bubbles
driven by air or fluid which is much
cheaper than existing electronic
displays that could cost up to fifty
five thousand dollars the challenge now
is to fit all five to ten thousand
physically controlled dots in a compact
mobile space the gyro glove aims to
control tremors in the hands of people
with Parkinson's disease
a mechanical gyroscope on the back of
the hand resists the hand movement
caused by tremors by up to 90 percent
they hope to launch in the UK by the end
of 2016 the first need to try to make it
spin silently and remain balanced
vertigo is a wall climbing robot the
collaboration between Disney researches
Erick and ETH easily transitions from
ground to wall by maximizing thrust and
minimizing vehicle weight it features
two propellers for thrust and a carbon
fiber baseplate to minimize weight
mostly I just want one
finally here's Boston Dynamics Atlas
robot doing some household chores I'm
gonna leave you with fly ability a drone
with the spherical freely rotating
protective cage and as always thanks for
watching
keeping in touch by means of the amazing
new bellboy if the bell systems answer
today for doctors salesmen delivery men
or anyone who must be available at all
times in the fast-paced world of century
21 when someone calls and you are out
you can be reached by dialing your
bellboy code numbers
when you get a signal on the bellboy you
can go to a phone to call your office or
home and get the message